I bet children do this look at my lychee
nipples Hilary please never bleach II
know I don't know what lychee is I know
what lychee the fruit is it comes in
brown skin to cause sweet and on the
very very inside is like a very smooth
pit they put those little in my drink
sometimes and it startled me
how do I eat it like a jello shot might
not even open it well the childproof is
on I need a grown-up to open this thing
it smells like perfume this is for
classy ladies to wear out not for
children to eat look if you see the
little chunks you can see through them
which is bizarre there's youth coming
out I just suck it oh it's so much
better tasting than it smells how much
your what that's really really good you
don't like it I can tell I don't mind
having another one mmm it tastes like
sugar and perfume and somehow that's not
terrible tasting and it had little like
bits of the fruit in it it tastes like a
fruit cup that I would get in my lunch
pail as a kid I feel like if hipsters
knew about this didn't love it I would
eat this is a kid because I worst things
in this I mean grew up in Brooklyn bro
talking it's like super underrated and I
think it makes everything better now I
have milking the Bulls I'm gonna do this
every time
Holbach smells like a bath and Bodyworks
Oh
very coconutty it's to coconutty
chemicals coconut did come cold and you
got a little bit too chewy coconut that
was delicious
all right let's get this out of the way
what I say mango is an overrated flavor
one time made something with a mango I
didn't like it smells like artificial
flavor
he's got dining hard chunks in it that
I've been avoiding halfway between a
mango lassi and mango juice from I can
horrible don't recommend any kid this
just seems like a delicious fruit snack
that American children are missing out
on this is the best candy I've ever
tried to taste that great children's
candy also great adult kick